[Music]
so much has happened since I last saw
you
I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh and then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
[Music]
Wow you have no idea I love the goddess
of death is invaded as God oh I miss
this
and you know you had a flag race tonight
did I win no I want easily this inside
right that's true
that's God is dead it'll be reborn in my
image I thought you'd be Claire to see
me
near the stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
at the old days
[Music]
surprise this would be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
here we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
by the same unit I'm just a couple of
hotheaded fools yes I'll collect fire
door like water kind of like fire but a
whole like raging fire so I like
smoldering fire
[Music]
they I know what you're thinking
how'd this happen
well it's a long story
[Music]
God is dead
[Music]
[Music]
what have you brought today tell me
[Music]
it's main event time
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
we know each other he's a friend from
work
[Music]
I guess I'm just taking a break we had
this really cool adventure saving earth
and that was pretty happy anyway so I
needed some me time and I came to
Australia and that's when I moved in
with Daryl hello
and here we are you know it's a nice
flat as you can see and we get along
well yeah I guess I just wanted to be
around average everyday people and Daryl
with an average sort of everyday guy so
it works out well while I'm here I'm
trying to get involved with the luggage
who's this purple weirdo surprise who
actually knew that was to give back to
the community
Daryl here is the new craft electronic
letter and right into Captain America
and Iron Man there seems to be something
very intense going on between them and I
want to offer my help with my services
dear Tony Stark how's it going I've
heard you and Captain America we're
having some relationship problems dear
Steve Rogers do you remember when i
goaded you into killing those prisoners
and you made me swear to never tell the
other Avengers if there's any other
secrets you need kept just let me know
because I'm not up to much what are you
doing later I was just working what's he
doing he's working keep out Daryl
costume for battles the real me over
here taking a nap something I've been
roasting in the Sun for a number of
weeks now it's almost already delicious
question what are Infinity stones Oh a
lot of information and ideas and what I
like to call this will Clues speckles
around the place and who is the man in
the purple chair it's purple is a magic
glove doesn't like standing up fury what
does he really know and is fury his real
name has it actually pronounced furry
little mill near here there are
sunglasses in case get bright and the
Rainbow Bridge which often it does if
you lift up this whole thing what's he
holding me
I never wear cut-offs how do I keep
waking up and coming off small new pants
going in cut-offs coming out yoo-hoo
mm-hmm oh my bike we heard from Tony
Stark in Captain America I've been in
contact you I haven't received a single
phone call one second hey t-bone how
many times do we have to go over this no
amount of money is gonna get me to join
your little pissing contest what yeah
talk to Thor yeah
he's sort of been waiting hear from you
I have him right here oh you can't right
now okay am I disappointed that they
didn't invite me to fight with them
no yes touch with you I don't have a
phone he doesn't have a phone I send a
raven I just start my own team team four
of course and it would be me and Aaron
just us right D yep I can't pay rent
with these things one's a pumpkin and
these Asgardian coins they're not worth
it in Asgard those coins these coins are
worth gazillion human dollars okay
gazillion you're rich
no one will exchange these go to the
market set up a store Yeah right
yeah Asgardian where previously owned by
four I'm a celebrity that will sell like
hotcakes you might need to think about
getting a getting a job yeah I have a
job you know my job is I saved the
planet it maybe you should get a job
mmm I have a job really eating the
machine with the words that come out of
it this is knowledge knowledge is power
no it's not knowledge is not power
that's power the brain is a muscle and
that's a muscle and that's a muscle
there you're all muscles this is all
muscle so I am covered in brains and I'm
more brains than you so do you think
maybe we could just think that when you
deserve it I don't think we can get a
surgeon to get us so we could settle
we're getting a servant
[Music]